good morning Hank it's Tuesday yeah I do
say Tuesday we deal with them if you
didn't know on the other nerd factor
when I known as nerdy and quirky hi
following the pattern formed by previous
videos I am NOT John I'm about as not
John as possible what I am is a 15 year
old living in the modern era
experiencing teenage life and noticing
all the unfortunate things my peers and
I do so Hank if you like a ghost in a
Dickens novel to warn you about the
annoying things your niece and nephew
might do at least according to a
stereotype Oprah hands friends and
social life will basically become more
important than anything else I'm not
being exclusive to social interactions I
take place in real life because that
would probably involve going outside and
let's be honest Sabrina it's time for
dinner not now Alex and I are we writing
the Book of Mormon
what I'll eat later diets will range
from eating no food the whole day to
eating all the food in the world let me
tell you if I'm left to my own devices I
will forget to eat the whole day until
the sound of my stomach growling is
louder than the YouTube video I'm
watching and then on microwave something
probably a bag of popcorn then I'll eat
a bag of chips then some crackers
probably some cheese then to counteract
how salty that was I'll probably eat
some ice cream or cake there's science
to it the science of delicious next they
will fangirl this affects both genders
this fangirling may be targeted at
people said people may be older than you
it's kind of weird but don't worry too
much about it also there will be a stage
in life when main coding is done on
ironically I'm staring straight into the
Sun because Yolo then it's gonna move
too it's ironic usage make bananas in
the toaster yo no then this usage will
continue until it once again becomes an
ironic catching up on current events yo
know there will also be slurred speech
yeah I don't shut up because me and
these are really on a recom date on the
fly because the max will understand well
you my friend on the taste right you're
so right
yeah bad vision you are the prettiest
thing I've ever seen and ever no wait I
changed my mind you are no wait change
my mind again trouble breathing how's
your day weird these are starting to
sound like medicine warnings as if the
very act of aging is like taking
medicine the experience is making us
more mature and intelligent with
possible negative
defects did I actually just pull a
metaphor out of that yes I did
what do you mean oh is a stretch excuse
you who do you think I am John Green
Hank I'll see you on Friday